The right choice is the third one, as
you may have guessed. The operating system is
multiplexing the CPU among the competing applications. You
may have multiple cores, but you don't have one
core for every application that is currently running
on the CPU. It may be that you've
only have one core. Or, exactly one CPU.
In which case, it is the operating system that
is multiplexing these applications to run, at
different points of time on the CPU.
And that's what is giving you this
appearance as though, there are multiple programs
running concurrently on the processor. But they're
not running concurrently. It is just that
they're being multiplexed, so that its appearance
as though, they're all running in parallel.